Let's put our hard one knowledge of these new regular expressions
like any character except new line or set compliment of what we've been talking about
to the test.
I'd like you to submit via the interpreter, assign to the variable regexp,
a Python regular expression that matches double-quoted string literals
and--this is the sticker--allows for escaped double quotes.
Let me just jump over to the interpreter briefly to show you what I'm talking about,
and then we'll come back here.
It turns out that there is 1 of those gritty details in this problem that makes life fun,
but also complicated the first time.
The sorts of strings that I want you to accept are like this one down here.
"You say, and then there's a \yes\, I say, no.
We've got \no\ and then it ends.
This is a well-formed, well-balanced string literal with double quotes
and some escaped double quotes.
However, to get it to Python, remember that Python is going to treat the escaped sequences,
meaning no literally the next thing.
But what if you want to literally have a backslash?
Then you need to escape the escape sequence.
It is turtles all the way down, my friends.
So if you want to do some testing on your procedure,
here this string 1, this is what you'd have to enter into Python
in order to get it to be the sort of string we're looking for.
Here I started with single quotes, and then I've double escaped this backslash,
then the double quotes, double escape again.
Here I've added 2 more, just to make this extra clear.
All 3 of these are positive examples--whoops! I'm so wrong!
I have forgotten the closing double quote at the end of '"I say, \\"hello.\\"'.
This is a negative example.
Let's go fix it. There we go. Add in another quote.
Now all 3 of these are positive examples of the sorts of strings you'd want to match.
You say, yes. I say, no.
I do realize that there should be a quote here,
but I've intentionally left out the apostrophe in don't,
so as not to confuse the issue since we're already talking about quoted strings.
So here just to remind you, I've written out a positive example and a negative example.
On the left is what you'd have to say to Python and on the right is what it means.
And the big hints are that you'll probably want to escape the double quotes and the backslash,
just like we did here.
You may want to consider having parenthesis nested inside other parenthesis.
This one's tricky. Good luck!